Ecuadorian president Guillermo lasso
looks increasingly isolated as he begins
the latest fight for his political life
he surrounded himself with supporters
and his wife as he rejected the second
impeachment trial against him in less
than a year this time for allegedly
embezzling public funds he insisted he
is a victim of a conspiracy against him
I am outraged by this attack on my
Integrity my reputation and also that of
our home with my hand on my heart
ecuadorians I reiterate to you I am
innocent
this week the country's constitutional
Court gave the go-ahead for the
impeachment proceedings against the
conservative former Banker the court
accuses him of allowing corruption in
the country's State oil companies
and it comes as lasso struggled to
tackle a surgeon violent crime and
worsening economic problems
he now faces a vote in a hostile
Congress and abysmal approval ratings
even conservative observers in the
country say it has become increasingly
hard for any political sector to defend
them
this impeachment trial is happening
after lasso suffered heavy defeats on
local elections and in a referendum last
month among a worsening security crisis
there is also a crisis in the health
system and I think the generalized
discontent might play a role in pushing
legislators to make a political decision
more than a simple judicial one
the National Assembly is up to 45 days
to investigate the charges housing lasso
will require 92 of the assemblies 137
votes other political experts fear the
removal could impact Ecuador's already
weak institutions but insists the
president as only himself to blame
one could worry about the economic and
social effects that this political
crisis could have in Ecuador but the
reality is that it's the economic and
social crisis in the country that
brought us to this point
this impeachment trial is nothing else
than a way of trying to solve the whole
set of failures of lasso's
administration
if the vote to remove him passes lasso
would be replaced by vice president
Alfredo borrero a former medical doctor
and a political novice the lasso could
instead choose to dissolve Congress
before the vote triggering fresh
elections that given the president's
approval ratings most believe he would
certainly lose Alessandro al-jazeera